all right welcome everybody to another
ideas that matter conversation I have
here with me T Virgil Murthy and I'm
very happy that we're going to be
talking about somebody who I geek out
about quite a bit and I think she does
even more oh I very much do yeah so I
get to call upon somebody who has
greater expertise in a topic than I do
which is a nice treat for me um Virgil
is is a PhD candidate in philosophy
studying philosophy of statistics and
philosophy of disability and she co-runs
the addict Collective blog which that's
a substack right you can find it there
or am I mistaken about that uh it it's
it's currently at addict collective.
substack
docomo another domain name but still
that link should be functional so find
her there and uh you can find her on
Twitter and I'm I'm guessing some other
social media as well that we'll talk
about towards the end and she's got some
Publications coming up in feminist
philosophy quarterly and the Journal of
philosophy of disability but today we're
we might talk about some of those topics
um you know along the way here but today
we're talking about Jorge Lou B Jorge
Louie Louise bores uh mangled the name
right there and it's cool to find
somebody who not only I think we got
into this conversation on Twitter
because you'd pointed out that people
were getting certain stories wrong
typically in the way that they were
portraying them and that's a topic I
really want to pick your brain on
because I I've seen that too though
probably not to the ging extent that you
have because I'm not as connected to
Borge's circles but you've also
translated some of Borge's stories right
yes yes um and I have sort of an ongoing
project about it that I'd like to spend
more time on but I've translated a
couple um I have publicly available
translations that I've done of um
library of Babel and of ton um but I
tend to be and and these are for very
specific reasons and they're stylized
I'm not a trained translator and there's
a lot of regards in which I'm not as
well positioned with authority for a
translation as other people might be
these are geared towards very specific
things which are themes in the stories
or particular lines in the stories that
I feel have been generally mistranslated
or mis deployed but the um people not
understanding borase in the way that I
personally think you know is is correct
is sort of one of the bogeyman of and
bins of my existence I was in the car
recently um and and and my partner was
like oh I have I found this podcast
where people are discussing bores let's
put it on you'll hate it um because
because it were you know these kinds of
conversations about bores that were
being had are claiming things about his
interpretation of infinity or of
immortality that I think are
misinterpretations or whatever but but
like all people are I think about their
specific you know interests that are
close to their heart I can get pretty
particular and um oftentimes even even
caddy about my interpretation of Boris
and about things that I feel are
misinterpreted in public discourse so
you you mentioned
immortality and um there's a couple
stories where he's playing around with
that right but did you have in mind uh
The Immortal as the main one that you're
talking about or a different one yeah I
was thinking about I was thinking about
the immortal it's one of the more famous
ones and there's a lot of public facing
conversation about it um which often
seems to revolve
around this sort of commonplace
fashionable idea that mortality is what
makes life meaningful right or that you
know when when somebody is living
forever they run out of things to do and
they run into this pervasive sense of on
we I really don't think that's what
bores is trying to get across with that
story yeah um I think you're right about
that I I I don't see that in that story
either and I think that that Trope is
very common in Vampire
literature and also in you know movies
like Highlander you know um at least
with that one you got the spice of oh
there could only be one so we have to do
like sword duels and cut each other's
heads off and all that but the the idea
well what are you going to do with all
of this time the other thing that seems
to come up with that um which I I
suppose could fit into that story is any
relationship that you have is going to
be not just finite but it's going to be
a small part of the extended life that
you have right and you could right like
a sort of uh what's what's the the
tropes name for this uh mayfly December
romance right yeah which I I I I
Shameless lifted it from the TV Tropes
website I think calls it that which is a
pun on May December but but this sort of
oh you this Mortal on who you know who's
been lucky enough to have this small
portion of of my eternal life you are
just a mere Speck in my existence Ponder
my power there really you know an
element of that you mentioned vampire
literature and vampire media yeah and
there's that theme a lot as well yeah
the and and it strikes me that you don't
have to look at it that way as an
immortal being you could say um well you
know look at how fleeting these things
are I need to take a special care of
them I shouldn't uh I I I don't have to
not get attached but I just have to be
cognizant of the fact that they're going
to die sort of like I mean I'm not going
to say that this is exactly the same but
when we have pets you know when we adopt
a puppy or a kitten I suppose it's
different if you adopt a turtle because
they live so long but you know if you
adopt or MAA I'm a big fan of MAA yeah
uh they might outlive you but if you if
you get a puppy or a kitten unless
something happens to you or you're very
old probably you're going to bury that
that animal and so does does that mean
that like you shouldn't get attached to
them I don't think so so it means you
should value the time that you you have
um but you know before we jump into this
you should probably tell people just in
case there's you people who haven't read
much more well what is this story The
Immortal what's what's going on in
it oh should we just give like a like a
summary yeah why don't you do that
because you know I've I've read it quite
a few times but I'm willing to bet that
you probably have a better take on it
than I do so I'll try to keep the keep
keep my personal you know opinions out
of the summary and keep it brief as well
basically um there is a person a sort of
you know ancient figure who is looking
for this vehicle it's it's a stream of
water that can make you immortal um he
and his his you know sort of comrades at
Arms run into various sorts
of you know VAR sorts of fights or or
tribulations eventually he's the only
one left um along the way they meet or
or are seeing in the distance these
figures who are
trogloditas who seem to be living in
this way that to the sensibilities of
the Explorer guy parse as savage or
primitive um ultimately he he makes it
to the city that is supposed to be the
work of these ancient Immortal people
who've had who've had access to this
water and it just looks terrible um this
is sort of of a profound turning point
of the story he he he looks at the city
and it's very
aarian and it seems to be built without
meaning or without cause there's turrets
facing different directions he finds it
very
upsetting um he he he almost vomits at
the site and then he stumbles and he he
you know sort of splashes some water on
his face or drinks from a stream which
ironically unbeknownst to him turns out
to be the immortality stream uh he ends
up confronting this one trite figure
who's been following him around who he's
nicknamed Nam Argos which is the name of
ads' dog from from The
Odyssey um and he starts to talk to
Argos uh seeing some sort of signs of
intelligence or parsing of his words he
tries to train Argos to speak and
communicate um it turns out that this
this trite figure Argos is one of the
Immortals the toogit are the Immortals
and this is how they live and and and
maintain their society and this
particular trite is the poet Homer who
wrote the Odyssey um that's sort of
where the action of the story ends um he
he spends time in and out of these
societies he lives among the trites
dwells there uh inherits from their
Collective knowledge he spends time in a
variety of different regimes Witnesses
historical events um and then
he drinks some of this water again in
circumstances I forget and reverses the
immortality
and and and the postcript written by
bores is that this story that's been
told so far was found in a copy of the
Alexander Pope ilot right um in a in a
bookstore that was run by this guy in
one of his various instantiations and
personas across the year that he was
that he was this book seller and the
note indicates that the the author of
the note believes beles that the
preceding narrative has been a forgery
because it stylistically inherit and in
many places quotes with that
attribution a lot of extant literature
that preceded it um it's this amalgam of
various sources and that sort of the end
have I left out anything
important I don't think so um I I will
actually read one you brought up the
city so this is a a
line uh and it's italicized in the the
version that I have um I suppose to
emphasize that this city I thought is so
horrific that its mere existence the
mere fact of it's having endured even in
the middle of a secret desert pollutes
the past and the future and somehow
compromises the Stars so long as this
city endures no one in the world can
ever be happy or courageous I do not
want to describe it a chaos of
heterogenous words the body of a tiger
or a bull poll Polla with teeth organs
and head monstrously yolked together yet
hating each other those might perhaps be
approximate images and you know I mean
that that reads rather like the pros
that you find in weird stories with
Lovecraft or um other you I suppose you
could say Robert Howard or even uh
Katherine Moore will say things like
that every once in a while and um you
know I mean that's a pretty strong
statement No so long as this city exists
even though none of us know about it
nobody can ever truly be happy I mean
that what that means is none of us have
ever truly been happy uh perhaps human
beings were before the city was was
constructed so that's got to be
hyperbole right of of some degree um
yeah and it's very interesting
because the the city of the Immortals in
the story you know in sort of it ends up
being sort of a McGuffin right um it's
the motivating feature of this Quest but
it ends up being totally irrelevant to
the main plot and in many ways sort of
just a weird red herring yeah he gets to
the city and then it turns out that's
not even end act
one that's just the the quest turned out
to be a quest for something else all
along um so I wonder about this a lot
and people talk about this a lot with
why why is it that the city is so
horrifying and lovecraftian as you put
it why is it that it gets so much
airtime and
emphasis it's It's Tricky I tend to lean
toward the interpretation that it
is over that it's that it is a red
herring that when he's exploring this
city he's still inhabiting this world of
sort of temporal
mores um and he doesn't really
understand the purpose or the meaning or
or or any ostensible interpretation of
something that's such a stylistic
amalgam um which okay I'll back up a
little bit and say the immortal is a
story about translation oh interesting
how how so so I think that the key the
key of the interpretation is um the the
final postcript right the the governing
logic of the story the document in which
this important story is found is the
Alexander Pope Iliad which is an
extremely important historical work of
translation namely of of of Homer by
Alexander Pope um one of the best I I
think it's one of the best translations
it also is you know it captures Ryman
meter in a way that's a lot of uh modern
translations of of of The Iliad either
deliberately stylistically don't do or
or deliberately subvert or just sort of
Despair at the concept of reproducing um
it's a translation and and the question
that goes alongside translation is is it
actually possible to maintain the
original Spirit of a text when you
translate it um there's something that's
sort of like almost sapper wary here
yeah but more to the point
um sort of sort of there there's there's
an inherent question there about the
fatalism of language and communication
which is something that bores is always
on about in his other works and I think
he very much at the end of the day is
not a fatalist about language in the
project of communication um there's
something inherently contradictory in
writing dozens and dozens of stories
each one finding a new way to say
there's nothing new to say if somebody
does that in their literary career
you're right to ask whether they're
doing it satirically um and I think that
he is so so this process of translation
comes across in the medm of the Pope
Iliad and comes across in the in the
postcript note that says well this this
preceding narrative has been this
amalgam of various extent pieces of
literature what you see then is that the
project of translation is about not
just taking something and Faithfully
reproducing it but about building
something new out of assembled pieces
that aren't necessarily original in
themselves you build something original
out of pieces that aren't original which
is what this ostensible author you know
who was Immortal and then wasn't has
done so I think that's what the city is
meant to represent it's an amalgam
there's nothing there that makes any
sense to the o to the you know this the
Voyager in his first iteration he
doesn't really see it for what it is he
can't understand it it just looks
horrible looks like a travesty and that
line of as long as this exists nobody
can ever be happy I think
reflects that it reflects that sort of
fatalism that B has puts in this
Viewpoint character of
you can't just build things like this
they're fundamentally meaningless and
more they're actually just
atrocities um they're noise and they're
Devastation they're actively adverse to
human knowledge but then the irony is
that later on in the story he is accused
of doing the same thing by the
commentarius who's saying well this was
just an amalgam of discret parts and
therefore I think it's false in the same
way that the city is this conflicting
blend of various objects that doesn't
make sense when he parts it um his
Reflections on his experience are parted
that some way by that same way by
someone else so that's why I think that
bores doesn't really mean that point
about the city at face value he's
representing this interpretation toward
translation and toward literary
combination but then he's subverting it
with the project of the story so there's
really something that's like allegory
going on between the first part and then
the second part of the
story um but it's not it's not easy
allegory where you can be like oh here's
the surface story here's the Deep story
here's What's um you know if we want to
use signifying signified kind of
semiotic language here's the here's the
signifier here's the
signified they they both reference each
other and you get a
richer story that way so switching to
talking about
translation um you know I I've done a
lot of translation myself from French
and Latin and some sometimes you know I
Supply my own translations for Greek or
German and when I first started
translating I um I produced translations
that a lot of people found
unsatisfactory because they they seem to
uh literal to them and I wanted to
retain like what you were talking about
a translation this idea that a
translation should adequately express
everything that's there including the
style in somebody else's work
and you know I I thought well a
translation should sound like a
translation it shouldn't sound like
perfect English Pros because then then
you're not like pretending that you're
reading something that was written in
English and eventually I think this is
very like that that the translator is
supposed to be uncannily aware and the
reader supposed to be uncannily aware
and that's the only way to be respectful
of the original text is if it is really
clear this is a translation yeah like
that that sensibility you're expressing
it makes sense to me and I think that
that's commonly thought of translation
yeah and eventually I I found myself
abandoning that because and it was it
was not because I had a better model or
anything to turn to but because I
realized there weren't any good models
for what a great translation or if there
were it would just be how to translate
this work so you could have you know
Pope's translation but that's not going
to help me at all when I go to translate
um Hegel from German you know
um I mean I I could try to keep hegel's
obscurity in the English translation I
suppose but that's not doing anybody any
favors you know and I I got to the point
where I think I became what would you
call it you know not like happy or
anything but just okay with a
translation being ah it's as good as
it's G to get you know and I could have
made other choices here and I found that
it actually made me much more forgiving
at least towards certain other people's
trans transtions not universally I would
still say a crappy translation remains a
crappy translation and I would criticize
them you should have done this over here
instead of this you know like when I'm
reading say Marcus orelias and I'm like
oh this is a this is really misleading
and the person should know that this is
going to mislead the English reader um
translating uh certain terms in in ways
that could be tricky which wind up like
figuring into quote Pages later on and
people just regurgitate that but I I've
been very forgiving towards let's call
it um anywhere from excellent to
intermediate translators in part because
I'm like well I can't translate that
well myself um and and you know that was
very liberating for me because it meant
I didn't have to be as ticked off with
as many people as I typically am I've
I'm somebody who struggles with anger
problems so it's important for me to
remove possible instances and I'm
curious so I'm I'm imagining that you've
probably had kind of a trajectory
yourself in your own approach to
translation and I'm willing to bet that
it's significantly different from my own
um how how how do you view translation
the act of it what are what are you
aiming at when you're doing
it so I I want to find this one file on
my computer which is a a translation I
did once that captures this clearly and
if I hopefully I'll be able get around
to it later and find it okay um if we
come back to this but but but in the
meantime on the topic of
translation I tend to agree with what I
take as boris's ultimate view of
translation he talks about this as as I
claim in you know in Immortal he talks
about it in in Clon even though it's
just a sentence or two okay um he it's
it's very implicit throughout Babel it's
very it's it's very explicit throughout
uh the search of
aist um right right we should talk about
that one that's a good one it's um and
what what I think comes across really
interestingly is the Mandate the project
of translation as positive and creative
and importantly the translator's
contribution that you are not a passive
vessel who is taking who is just a to it
who's taking something from point A to
point B where it Remains the Same you
know untainted by anything that you
thought about anything of your own
personality and it's just you know
available to a wider audience but rather
it becomes an amalg Amalgamated feed it
becomes your work and also the work of
the original author um and as successive
translations you know proceed as people
translate than maybe the translation
that you did into still other languages
um or or even if you're just even even
if you're a translator in the very
occupational sense right say you are a
translator um between you know between
between English and and ASL what you are
doing in that capacity is generative and
involves your intellect involves your
creativity involves your parsing of
things and your world view um we can
despair about that and say that this
means translations are tainted and
they're not Pure or we can regard it as
sort of a grudging inevitability or we
can celebrate it and try to interpret it
as transgressive and interesting in some
way in and of itself and my my my
opinion is very much the latter okay um
the fact that you can't that there is no
such thing is a is a pure translation
isn't
really you know bad in much the same way
that somebody who who doesn't who
doesn't speak the language that some
original um was written in can can't
necessarily access that original and
what the author meant by it and engage
with the text and has to engage through
the translation in that same way
somebody who doesn't speak the second
language can't engage with the
translation and with the work of both
those authors in concerts so there is
always you know epistemic access that
some people have and that some people
don't and your positionality with
respect to what languages you know or
don't know Etc confers opportunities it
doesn't just build
fences yeah I think it's very cool
I suppose too there's this idea lurking
out there that um some people have and
it might be analogous to the idea that
people have about like what it is when
you've really mastered a philosopher and
their their works that there's something
and maybe we get this from video games
or from other things like there's
certain like levels or you know you can
you can reach a certain point where
you've mastered
something and I I think that's that's
just not the case so like you
know translating Aristotle for example
right so just even reading Aristotle I
know very few people who've read every
single text that we think is by
Aristotle including a lot of Aristotle
Scholars because you'll you'll mention
things to them from the topics and
they're like oh yeah haven't uh read
that section before I should go take a
look at that and there's this this
tendency I think among people who
haven't tried to do translation to think
that like well we could like rank
translations maybe in some sort of
absolute order you know this one's
closest to the original text well how I
mean it's an epistemological problem how
the hell would you know that unless you
actually read the original text um and
assuming that there aren't like multiple
variations of the original text um and
then you you know you you look at the
the translations um I mean we can
definitely say some translations are
better than others like
it's easier at the low level we can say
oh this one sucks you know but like
which ones are the absolute best for
this this author um that gets very it's
very much relative to what we're looking
for gets it gets so subjective it gets
inherently bound up with our
interpretations of the original author's
intents right whether I mean even two
people can agree on on the way in which
a certain sentence should be phrased or
framed and still disagree on whether it
was meant sincerely or sardonically and
that can change everything there's all
these subtle differences and that's why
I think it's it's it sort of you know
saves us in a way to regard translation
as this meaningfully creative act
because otherwise we are just in such
big trouble yeah an interpretive act
right now I don't want to stay on
translation forever but one of the
things that I've liked about translating
works is uh um and maybe this stems from
a sort of laziness on my part I like
taking somebody else's words and just
trying to see if I can render them
effectively in in English because I
don't have to do any original thinking
of my own you know not like when I'm
doing my own work which isn't really
that original anyway most most of my
work is like in the history of
philosophy so I'm saying well what's
what's Aristotle saying and how does it
apply to our lives or what are the
stoics saying or what's I'm saying um
but I like to think there's a little bit
more hard intellectual work on my part
and it's not that translating isn't hard
intellectual work um but it's a
different modality of it just being able
to give somebody else voice in a
different language it for me it kind of
took the pressure off me and I'm
wondering if is is that at all like what
you must have some joy in translating
and so I I'll I'll shift the the topic
what's the joy that you get in
translating that's a good question and I
did manage to pull up this this file
that I was looking for that I wanted to
use as an example
um The Joy so the joy in Translation
that I am not really a translator by
trade and I think that all things
considered I'm really not very good at
it I'm better at some things than others
and the only other uh language that I'm
passible in besides besides English is
is is Spanish
I um there's something very exalting
about translation but there's also
something very technical about it okay
and the combination of those two things
has always interested me the other thing
that I study you know you remember when
you introduced me philosophy of
statistics and philosophy of disability
well those seem pretty different and in
a way they are um and and and this
tension is actually quite generative
that I really like to explore something
Technical and yet I also like to be able
to do that creatively which I think is
is is what a lot of math is about so in
translating in translating bores
although as I mentioned this has always
been more motivated by specific gripes
that I have with existing translations
um or with specific desires to like I'll
read it I'll read in Spanish and I'll be
like oh I this this sentence is so
important you know and then I I'm
motivated to translate because of that
um I
translat um I've translated a little bit
of of of of Spanish poetry and of other
Spanish Pros I was really into Teresa
aala oh okay so Libra theu of course is
like you know the the book she's known
for but she has some poetry and she has
this one poem um which is in the Spanish
titled muo moo or um or VI me um which
is variously translated as I die because
I do not die um and the then the
parenthetical I live without life in me
um
so I I I have a translation of this that
I go back to and and look at a lot and I
look at the original a lot because it
expresses for me what I find so
interesting or generative about
translation um the
most apparent and interesting and
gripping features of the
original um are the meter and the rhyme
scheme it's right yeah it's it's a very
um specific meter and rhyme scheme and I
I'll read you a stanza and then I'll
read you a stanza of my
translation
um let
me okay here's the one I'll
do
so roughly this means um this Divine
Union that she's in and the Amore that
she the sorry the love that she lives
with makes God her captive and liberates
her heart it's a sort of inversion of
power between God and herself the pious
person and what causes her passion what
sort of you know creates her Liberation
and her excitement about her religion is
to
see that in some way this power Dynamic
is reversed that her love for God which
has liberated her heart makes God in a
sort of odd way her prisoner and the way
that I translated this is this heavenly
jail takes its part from the love in
which I stand in Rapture which permitted
me my God to capture liberating my own
dear heart so much do I have rise with a
start to see captive my God undying that
I die for want of dying um this is not a
faithful translation by any sense of the
word and I can and I can send you the
whole uh file it really I take
tremendous Liberties here and the reason
I do it is that what I am concerned with
is the meter in the scheme because the
meter in the scheme of this poem so
brilliantly capture this exaltation
she's feeling this soaring you know um
like this like like the tri it's it's
it's so beautiful and that's what I
sought to capture um I find that to be
at once very technical because you get
to the end of a line and you can't find
the right word and then you have to go
back earlier in the line and then you
have to change a word there you're sort
of trying to make all the all the Ducks
line up yeah yeah but then there's such
a sense of exaltation about it there's
such a sense when you can hear that the
the the verse that I read you in the
Spanish and then the verse that I read
you of mine in the English that the
meter sounds the same that the rhyme
scheme is the same that's the element of
translation the capture of which brings
me a sort of catharsis almost or a sort
of relief um I wonder if that makes
sense I feel it's a little AB no it does
um and and it makes
sense you know emotionally you talk
about catharsis or a sort of release
that comes with it so there's a there's
a tension
and then there can be a release and I I
was just thinking as you were talking
about this I I used to write sonets
quite a bit and I uh typically would
write patarin sonets which have the you
know more more difficult rhyme scheme
and I uh at a certain point you know
they're hard to write in English but
they're easy as hell to write in French
because there's so many possible end
Rhymes and and the words you know tend
to fit the the uh pentameter fairly easy
um so I would I would often just do that
you know and it's it's kind of a cop out
in a way you to pick the the language
that's easier to do that in and I wonder
with with going from Spanish to to uh
English is it more difficult to get
across some of these these um let's call
them not technical matters but the
matters of meter and uh stress and and
rhyme um the form maybe of of is it
harder to do that in English with these
Spanish poems because our language isn't
I mean it's it's got a massive
vocabulary right but it's also not as
easy to use in some respects for
poetry what do you
think I guess I still think Everything's
Relative I I absolutely think it's the
case that there are some part particular
and you know I'm not even sure that I
that I would agree that there are
certain schemes or certain structures
that are more conducive to some
languages than others
um but rather that there are certain
poems that are hard to translate and
often the difficulty translation and
Hees in some features of the language
that they're that they're written in
okay um and I think that this this
doesn't only persist auditorily it's
true also various other ways of
apprehending communication I mean there
are absolutely certain kinds of turns of
phrase right um in in ASL say um where
it's it's difficult to capture this and
sort of like you know and and and maybe
the catharsis for for a translator there
comes in distilling this in some way
that keeps the meaning but like a little
bit at the cost of the of the structure
or vice versa the same way that I felt
you know to some extent you sometimes
have to choose you have to Tinker with
one but not the other um there are
definitely often times I think it's the
it's the particular kinds of famous
poetic works that dictate um what kinds
of scheme or what kinds of meter we
regard as endemic to what languages oh
yeah yeah that that makes sense yeah the
paradigms you could say right the the
things you read the petar Sonet which I
also love I love the more complicated
scheme and I love the couplet at the end
um of a pican Sonet I find it to be so
beautiful yeah um sorry the the the sex
at the end of the petar I find it to be
more beautiful than the than the
couplet that's interesting um I mean
I've always found so the the you know
the four would it be an octet the four
where you've got to have uh four similar
end rymes two two two groups of four of
those that's difficult right and to get
that in there and then it seems like
you're going downhill with the six at
the end because now you only have to
find a few more more Rhymes and you've
already got the you know the meter
down but bringing them to a successful
close I found that difficult you know
you gotta have a really great end line
you know what I really like about the
structure the petar and Sonet is so
first of all I really like inverted
Rhymes I Love Abba okay um I use it
constantly in my own work I I um I've
read a lot of music and I appeal to this
rhy a lot oh um because it has this very
peculiar specific
structure that it's very different from
ABAB right or aab where it's like you're
coming around and tying something up in
a way that almost surprises The Listener
the time you get to the end of the
phrase they've forgotten about the the
first you know ending um phony there's
still a residence and then they get back
and they're like oh it was that so with
the you know with the like CDE CDE of
the um end of a petrarchan Sonet it
really raises that the next level it's
like I am throwing at you these three
different syllables at the at the ends
of of these three lines and you just
sort of they they didn't have anything
in common and they go somewhere in your
head and then I come back around and go
you know Bing Bang Boom and resolve them
each in turn and that is so pretty I
find it to be so pretty you know it's
sort of like in in a traditional song
you know you've got the the verses you
got the chorus and the you got the
bridge with a patarin Sonet you
basically got chorus chorus Bridge you
know which means that it's not a bridge
at all because it's a bridge has to be
in between some stuff it's like a break
from from something um in a way and I
don't know if you're going to like this
this analogy at all so Black Sabbath
when they first started coming out one
of the things that they're that's
characteristic of their songs that
they've remarked upon you know
reflecting on their songw writing
process lat ler is that a lot of their
songs are actually two or three songs
Smo together they're not one integral
song that has the uh traditional um you
know verse Verse Chorus Verse Chorus
Bridge Verse Chorus chorus kind of Pop
thing that you can do instead it'll be
you know you think about like um uh some
of their songs where they start out slow
and it goes slow for a while and then
it's a totally different song but it
fits that's now at like double speed and
they're they're smoed together and of
course there's a continuity because it's
the same instruments it's the same
singer um and it tends to be about the
same kind of stuff although there might
be some lyrical variation as well and of
it's it's in the same key or it's in a
key transition that makes sense that's
true too yeah yeah no I totally I
totally grasp the analogy I'm a big I
don't know how you feel about Le
Zeppelin I am I like them you know I'm
their biggest fan
okay which you probably I guess you know
I don't know whether listeners to the to
the series can will see my appearance or
whether it's just audio they will see it
yeah okay yeah so you probably guessed
you know I look like somebody who' be
really into Le zeppin and I am and it's
often the same sort of thing where it it
it inherits a lot from traditional
melodic traditional Notions of
developing a Melody you have a theme and
then you have variation I think Black
Sabbath does this as well
but then there's also okay we ran out of
stuff all we have is this other
unrelated thing but we're going to Retro
reccon it somehow in such a way that it
really fits and that is very wild to me
it's very cool yeah that that that's
true uh and sometimes bands will have
like a song that it turns out to be a
wonderful song but it was just filler
they needed one more song for the album
and so they're like who's got a riff you
know let's let's throw this together
find some lrics lyrics for this so yeah
um you know that's how uh Pinball Wizard
got into Tommy really is that uh T was
was was playing it they were playing it
for I don't know some some people who
were in some sort of position of
authority over the production of the of
the concept album and the guy uh used to
like play Pinball with with Pete Townson
in in in in bars or something and sort
of threw off his hat at the end of the
album was like this is such dark stuff
put a track in there about pinball and
it's it's to this day like you know the
song the only song that that that P town
in really really hates that the who's
ever written I might be exaggerating but
I remember that might be apocryphal but
that's a story that I've heard well
there there I mean there are um hits
that wind up being just totally
repudiated by the band I mean radio
head's creep is a uh prime example but
you could I was just talking about it or
Jamie's crying by Van Halen did they not
like that one that's
interesting um I think Eddie one of one
of them really really famously hates it
I there's even a few like uh songs off
of the early Metallica albums where
you're like no this is a great song but
the band doesn't want to play it anymore
I think like um Trapped Under Ice they
think is a a bad song and I I don't get
why they don't like it um but I was I
was actually thinking about Warren
cherry pie which was another one of
those filler songs and it became the
definitive song for that that band and
every time they go to a concert people
are basically just there to hear that
song you know and they hate it so you
know but I think they still play it um
they just save it for last you know the
way you typically do with these sort of
things well coming back to borase though
um so you know one of one of the other
um ones that I I wanted to talk about
was the lottery and Babalon and the
reason I wanted to bring that one up is
that's that's become my favorite Borge
story so before we get into that I
wanted to ask you and maybe there's h a
question to this or an answer to this
but maybe there isn't do you actually
have a favorite that you can say like
this is the top one for me or is there
like a constellation of your favorites
that you kind of bounce
between where where do you sit with
that I do have a favorite um and it's a
it's a common Choice uh the library of
Babel okay um and then I also I have
sort of tears right like there are
certain kinds of there are certain
stories that there there there's there's
not really any that I really hate but
there's some there's a bunch of stuff in
in Universal history of infamy that I
sort of don't get okay um or don't
understand how it coheres with the
project of the whole um there's a few
there there there there's always a few
there's a few INF fictionist that I feel
that way about um but yeah I guess my if
I were to give like a you know the the
super the S tier list okay um it's ton
obviously Baba which I named
um three versions of Judith which I
think is pretty pretty underrated on
exactitude in science which is also very
underrated and only a paragraph long
yeah um ais's
search um
I really like Amazons which is which is
not one of the super not one of the ones
that's super associated with the the
image of of bores that's modern but
which is really good yeah uh the
theologians um and the garden of forking
paths and these tend to also be the
stories about which I get most
univocally fixated when you know other
people have interpretations thereof that
I think are inaccurate or or what have
you and they tend to be the common a lot
of them are the really famous story
especially G working paths do you think
that's
because um there's just more
interpretations out there so you're
bound to run into them or is it because
you're effectively connected with these
stor so it's more like a how dare you
screw this up kind of kind of thing
about you know something that you're
you're really invested in I think it's
more the latter and it's I I'm framing
it partly for comedic effect as if I
just see red but of course you know I'm
not going on Rampages like every day
when yeah it's it's more just the the
stories for obviously non-incidental
reasons this the stories that I like
most are the ones where I have a
more attuned interpretive well-formed
idea of my own about what they are and
what they mean and what have you um so I
just I just parse i i i parse more when
other people talk about them I'm more
inclined to be pushing my own
interpretation and to be yeah you know
to to be be critical of other
interpretations nearly about you what's
your oh sorry oh go ahead I was gonna
ask what your your your favorites are
because you mentioned you you you really
like lottery in Babylon well ours ours
coincide to some degree um I really do
like uh ton in part because of um you
know the idea of like intruding into our
world I I actually wrote a piece a while
back about um chat GP P3 and andar or
terus um because it has a tendency to
corrupt our internet sphere so to speak
by making stuff up you know um I mean I
asked chat GPT about me and among the
things that it it got wrong were like it
it said I'd never ever been in the Army
there's no record of that anywhere and
it's like public record out there but
then I asked that if I published
anything and it did get my one book
right and then it attributed to me U uh
six books written by my colleagues and
then it made up a whole book yeah g chbt
hallucinations yeah are so funny so I
think I think tan is actually
really timely in in a certain way I I do
love garden of forking P that was the
one that actually got me into borase we
read it in a uh um world literature
class when I was in college and I was
like holy crap what is this and then I I
went out and bought labyrinths and and
then I later on found out that bores had
written a lot more because I'm not a
very good scholar in in some respects
you know uh I'm often a little bit
behind um I I really do like you know
the the uh library of Babel that's
that's a pretty cool one um this The
Immortal I I like quite a bit one that
uh you didn't mention that I I really
get a kick out of is the house of
aeran and it's because of the
idea really the only thing in it that I
particularly get captivated by 14 is
infinite right and so how do you um
parse that out a finite number is the
the the signal for something being
infinite and I thought that's kind of a
cool idea you know um and then you know
there's there's other ones 14 being the
seven and seven yeah the sacrifices well
it's it's um let me actually to the to
the
that's that's part of it but it also ien
heard House of ayrian in some time it
has 14 doors andate okay so the
suggestion is that 14 is what it
factually has but
that the Labyrinth could be the
world um it has infinite doors and I I
actually I mean I never got around to it
I always wanted to write a book called
14 parentheses infinite which which
would be like philosophical examinations
of 14 bores stories and saying this is
good enough you don't have to do anymore
uh because 14 will cover the whole
because for hey you know where to find
me if you want me to contribute I think
that's a super cool idea yeah that it
also it reminds me of the the ending of
library of Babel where he's like allow
me to explain how the finite is infinite
it's because the library is cyclical I
got to reread House of aan but but now
that you brought that up I had never
thought of that commonality before but
it seems like a similar
mathematical attempt to reconcile the
finite with the infinites you know I had
thought about like writing it as a a
book myself but now that you bring it up
like that it probably would be much much
better if it was done by 14 different
people who actually you know care quite
a bit about borase and and are
interested in it and I mean here you
know we're getting way off into like the
the weeds here but I would I would
actually think maybe so you have like
the story itself um maybe a few like
little selections from it and then you
have the person's essay and then like
each person who contributes to it would
have to write a short little
commentary on at least two of the
participants
essays and and they could be like
scathing oh this person has totally
gotten boraste wrong we put it in there
you know or it could be like affirmatory
or it could be adding something that was
missed or you know or it could be a
postcript as if that was a found essay
like bores would add to so maybe maybe
not but that would be funny no I think I
think that's that's an interesting idea
and so you know maybe maybe we'll do
this that I think that's kind of a cool
idea you know you'd have to get people
who play well with others as as we say
you don't want anyone who's just being a
jerk but um I I'm sure we could find
them so um how did we get on to that oh
we were talking about uh uh House of
aeria and so I you know I've got my my
you know favorite stories and then
there's there's some that kind of go in
and out like fud the memorius I always
thought was an interesting story and
like if I was going to do something
about Bor and philosophy it would
obviously have to go in there but I'm
not all that enthusiastic about it as
I I think part of that is because I used
to be really into philosophy of language
and now I'm less about that if you're a
philosophy of language geek that's
probably the story for you
right yeah no I I definitely think the
tonality is Diary of trist from Shandy
is now just
so permeated in in in in the Zeitgeist
okay right this sort of like recursive
like you're writing you know what what
what happens to you each day but after
the first day you're just writing about
that you've been writing like right
right this is now sort of a
wellestablished concept which I think
makes funus lose some of its
bite um so do you think that some of
these stories have a bit of a shelf life
um culturally that way like you know
because they you know you see this with
a lot of cultural products where where
they're held up as like holy crap this
is amazing look at what they're doing
and I'll give you an example that has
nothing to do with bores Citizen Cane
right everybody Raves about what a great
movie it is you watch it and you're like
eh I hope I'm not you know uh uh you
know you're not a citizen and Cane like
a fando or something that I'm offending
you but um you watch it and you're like
it's it's I get what they were doing but
people do this kind of thing all the
time now and it's not it's not gripping
me the way that it should do you think
that there's there's some Bor stories
that are like
that yeah I think that's inevitable I
mean there's almost like a fukan thing
where the the Mythos of the story or the
public you know op like with citizen
Kade right like the public perception
and the celebration of it itself
contributes to then when people go and
watch Citizen Kane they're not just
watching the movie as they as they would
have been in 194 they're they're
watching this accumulated thing and
there's all of these cultural signifiers
that are bound up signifier versus
signified as you yeah brought up earlier
I think the same thing is inevitably
true of
any contribution to culture
um and I I I tend to think even you know
with with those Bor his stories that
that are really clearly indexed to some
place in time they'll they'll at some
point later again they'll be relevant um
but yeah like like there there are
fluctuations
in the salience of different stories
over time yeah so do you have in mind
things like um Dees requium where when
he wrote it it was kind of fresh uh he's
writing it at the end of the 1940s
it's harder for us to relate to you know
this this notion that like the the
German Nation had basically like
devastated itself through starting this
this massive war I mean Germans nowadays
except for a few they swung to The Other
Extreme and they're like we're never
doing that sort of crap again you know
uh this is you know uh but they hadn't
in
1949 uh when that came
out Ram I think is very relevant still
there there are a lot of okay there's
there's a non-trivial subset of of of
VOR his stories that are
about I'm trying to figure out how to
say this in a way that
isn't just what's coming to mind which
is a self-hating protagonist okay um but
are quite a few of those yeah that's
what we have in Deutsch's recm it's very
much and very sently it's the major
point of Garden of forking paths um and
it comes up elsewhere to
um tale of the compass on the hero would
be one of those
yeah yeah um or or um the other death
which is one of the less known ones but
one of my favorite I for some reason I
left it out of my list of
favorites
um these these there there are a bunch
of stories he writes in which there is
sort of an individual who's engaged in a
very peculiar form of like something
like guess we'd call
hypocrisy
or sort of being acutely aware of the
aware of their own position like within
some marginalized group within a
marginalized racial group within a
marginalized I mean in in deutch's
recream it's disability right um and
then they turn around and sort of
inflict violence on others okay yeah um
and this is also I mean this is so so
Garden of foring paths has this similar
um you you know this this this the main
character is this agent of state power
right um I haven't really thought about
thinking about these stories grouping
them together Beyond just sort of like
that's what they have in common what
does that mean why does he talk about
this so much but I do think it's
interesting and I'm glad that you
brought it up I want to look more into
it if I had to just make a you know like
a like a a flash in the pan hot take
okay I would say I think that um I think
that the reason that this is something
borus writes about so much is that to
him it Bears constant reminding
that your access to you know through
through firsthand experience your access
to pain into suffering through you know
uh uh being oppressed to witnessing you
know like like violence against you yeah
this does not make you immediately in
univers ially aware of how to be a good
person it does not resolve the mysteries
of you know mistreatment of people yeah
um and often it creates sort of spots of
insensitivity of its own and I find this
to be very well taken because we because
because always there's going to be
somebody who is you know like like
William Lloyd Garrison who was famous
famous abolitionist who was one of very
few white people at the time who
sincerely seemed to uphold the
intellectual quality of um of black
people and who agitated for women's
inclusion then turned around and was
wildly anti-semitic he thought that
slavery was a Jewish invention that
people
always have these kinds of spots and it
seems doubly unjust when it seems
hypocritical in that way but it but it
does
happen and it's so so I think in that
sense he's he's issuing a
warning yeah that's interesting that
would make for an excellent uh piece I
think you know bringing out so actually
this is a good lead in um back to one of
the the topics that we started talking
about with one story but you know ways
people are getting boraste wrong could
include like what they're missing that's
actually in the stories because they're
so focused on so you know think about um
Garden of forking paths okay time is you
know it's it's not just one linear thing
it goes in different directions and the
paths sometimes come back together and
that's that's kind of a cool theme but
but there's you know there's more to the
story even just that story than that or
the library in Babel okay yeah there's
you know you reproduce whatever uh
random combination you're going to
eventually get a book right sort of like
the Shakespeare monkey Trope that people
throw around um to which you know
somebody pointed out recently on Twitter
I thought this is this is great that you
know we already have done that we're
monkeys just you know different kinds
and we did have a Shakespeare who wrote
Shakespeare you know um that's where you
end up if you and this actually I know
we're going to get to Lottery but it's a
very similar upshot to Lottery of
Babylon you end up in this very absurd
epistemic space if you are regarding
people as these kinds of Agents of
chance um a while back I I thought I
would do something on Twitter where
every day I post sort of like a like a
piffy sarcastic one- sentence summary of
a different Bor his story and I'm gonna
get back into it but the one that I had
for um library of Babel which I think is
very important to note was written when
Bor so Bor has ultimately went blind he
was he was low vision already when he
wrote it okay um and yet it's this story
about cited media um and so the one
sentence summary that I that I wrote of
library of Babel was some cited nerds
learned about math and now we all have
to suffer because I do think this is
important and that's actually why I
wrote the my own translation of of
because I think everybody gets it wrong
what's really important to the story is
that the combinatorial theory oh there's
these different graphemes and they're
just randomly interpers in these
combinations and that's what the
universe is that is not an objective
theory of the reality of the universe it
is a mathematical theory about how
reality works that was itself devised
because some guy hundreds of years ago
according to the narrator read a book in
the library that taught him
combinatorics and he learned about
repetitions with you know he learned
about uh permutation with unlimited
reputation allowed yeah and then he
devised this Theory but it really is
just a theory and then it has all of
these like horrifying uh radical
consequences that bore his details to
the Viewpoint of the narrator with
people being thrown off balconies uh for
hundreds of years or with garden of
forking paths um the the short pity
sentence I had there was thought the
many world hypothesis could save you
from internalized racism Did You Wrong
and this one in particular I get very
animated about garden of forking P
because I feel it is very canonically
misinterpreted as being about like the
mysticism and universality of you know
Choose Your Own Adventure everything
could have been different yeah when in
reality the ending of the story turns
that so on its
head this guy opens his you know opens
his arms in his home and shares his
mystical theories of the universe with
this
visitor who then suddenly shoots him and
it is the death of that in a meaningful
way I don't think it makes sense to
interpret bores as speaking positively
of the contextuality and the mod like
the modal worlds and you know there's
one world in which this happens another
world in which this happens the guy who
thought that in the story got
immediately shot yeah these kinds of
these kinds of like sort of sardonic
commentaries of bores um I think I think
are so interesting and are often not
addressed with sufficient seriousness in
the investig ative literature because oh
my gosh that's so important that in the
garden of forking paths that whole
metaphysical theory that it's taken to
be propounding gets satirically
destroyed at the very end of the story
it's a shocking twist and it's
devastating and it really serves to
undercut that theory do you think that's
because people aren't attending to the
story as a
totality as an actual like work and
they're doing what um I mean
philosophers are are pretty bad for this
um whether they're Continental or or
analytic is zeroing in on like you know
this one part that we're interested in
then just ignoring all the
rest I think that's definitely a big
part of it there's a pick and choose
phenomenon I think there's
also there's this weird sort of SE like
implicit separateness between bores as a
Storyteller and bores as a philosopher
okay uh which you see a lot in something
like okay so I mentioned Universal
history of in for me and I mentioned
Amazon and I'll also mention the South
um because these there's a big
difference between stories like those
and then a story if we can even call it
like call it that like the one that
we've been through a distance talking
about namely uh Lottery and Babylon yeah
which is or like ton also these are very
different kinds of things it is not
really a narrative in that same way
parts of it are narrative but that isn't
really the thrust of the of this it's
more it's painting a vignette of how the
world could be it's this meaningful
speculative project in a way it's an
alternate history right because um
you're thinking about you are telling a
story but it's not a story about
individuals as individuals who we care
about as characters it's about like what
their relevance was to this encyclopedia
project that spills over into Clan or I
guess you know the lottery in Babylon
you know we do have a narrator and he
tells about what his dad told him but
he's really telling and and he's he's
waiting for a boat like there's things
happening but the action is his relaying
of this story yeah and stories like that
by bores are meaningfully not
character-driven but then there's this
Con this conflict because the garden of
foring paths is character-driven and
that's a huge deal and that what's makes
that's what makes the whole thing work
is that there's this person who is a
character who has this set of
motivations very idiosyncratic set of
motivations and I think that's part of
the reason Beyond just sort of the
cautionary tale that being oppressed
doesn't make you immediately able to
apprehend and and and act with kindness
there's also this other feature which is
because this is such an idiosyncratic
motivation it gets this main character
it may it really parses like nobody's
going to read that story and forget that
this that this man is living in an
oppressed you know he he he's an
oppressed person um and he's working for
his oppressors in order to prove to them
that he's smart well but they but they
are forgetting it like you're saying um
when they focus just on the oh you know
like you called it and I think this is
really app the Choose Your Own Adventure
and that refers to these Choose Your Own
Adventure books that we used to get as
kids where you're like you know do you
attack the Snake turn to page 87 and
then find out oh and you always like
kept your finger in the thing in case
you made the wrong choice
backtrack um I I think that is that is
what most people probably do with garden
of forking paths as a matter of fact
thinking back to when it was introduced
to us in that um world literature class
I think that's what the the teacher
focused on the most and he was a lit
teacher so you'd think he'd be caring
about the characters but I don't think
he did you
know what I what what I mean is more
that it doesn't tend to go without
mention okay um whereas sort of like
like character oriented details in other
Bor stories do do sometimes not Merit a
mention whereas this one in in Harden
tends to get mentioned um it's very
Unforgettable I think um in the sense
that people don't forget to say it the
way in which it's forgettable is that
people seem to not be regarding it as
the really important Motif that's
important to story parsing that it is um
that's sort of my I don't know I I I do
think this is Downstream of this
disconnect between viewing bores as
making some sort of philosophical
statement about the world and viewing
bores as telling a story
um and in some cases it does seem like
he's doing one or the other but in
Harden he really is doing both and they
interact really importantly the
storytelling the the the forward thrust
The Narrative the objective of the
character and then his deployment of
that
objective interact really importantly
with the metaphysical theory of reality
that borus is mounting in such a way
that it comes across on reflection as if
the medical theory is being met metap
metaphysic did I say medical
metaphysical theory of reality is being
critiqued rather than than forwarded you
know that that raises a really
interesting um question and I I don't
know if you have a a stance on this
would you say that there is some sort of
overarching here's what borase actually
thinks about reality that he's worked
out and we can say that that it's
philosophical um or is it that he's got
like several different you know takes
that he's playing around with and and
maybe three of them could be in his mind
true but he's not quite sure which one
so he weaves them into the stories one
would make him essentially an allegorist
and he he didn't like allegory you know
he says that um in in one of his essays
um and then the other one would I guess
suppose make him a kind of pluralist we
could say um he's not just somebody who
just says oh here's a philosophical idea
let me see if I can weave it je a story
right make some make some uh progress
with getting some words on the page it's
clear that he has some some views about
things but is there do you think there
is like an
overarching thing that um it doesn't
necessarily have to appear in every
single story but that would make sense
of it like there's a I know a boraste
code that we could call out I think
there are a few uh
Central themes or convictions that that
that that pop up a lot in boris's work
um I don't know if it's he I don't think
he's really a systematic philosopher
right where it's where it's a grand
Theory of Everything But I mean you know
sort of the the the canonical thing is
um he's
saying
stop sort of like fixating on fatalism
and anti-anti yourself out of doing
things yeah that's sort of a big a big
upshot um like I think that that that
comes across a lot in almost every story
that we've discussed it's very
particularly present in babell it's
particularly present in Lottery
um there there there there's a lot of
things that one is Central but it's not
an exhaustive description of what Boris
is and it also is the case that he just
is a guy who is as driven by whim as
anybody else and he writes things
because he he just likes them and he has
his interest and his dispositions I mean
why does he writes why does he have sort
of this like sociocultural fixation on
certain aspects of agrarian Argentinian
culture why does he have almost an
obsession with with Jewish mysticism
yeah um I don't think these are like
ciphers that will lead us to understand
what his stories meant I think it's just
what he that these were just interests
that he had like yeah or bringing up the
fact that he has you know English uh
ancestors and you know know which then
leads him to studying Anglo-Saxon which
is kind of a weird choice for anybody
you know um he was also uh he and this
is something you know that he and I
share as you know he was a big fan of
Dante um and he wrote about
Dante yeah you you'd mentioned that um
that's somebody who you also do work on
right um do you I it'll be a little bit
of a detour but what is it that
particularly attract you to
Dante if I had to say it in three words
I'd say god-shaped hole okay
so it's I don't know it's very it's very
complicated there there is sort of a
reason why the Comedia is one of
these profound works of literature that
people that that that always attract
this sort of you
know almost like like like violently
adoring fan base you know among whose
number account myself three years um I
read it my first year of college um and
I
just there there are scant few stories
or narratives or poems or any sort of
media movies what have you where I I
consume this media and then I can't
sleep for nights after I've read it and
I'm just thinking about it and thinking
about what it means and almost not
necessarily worrying like in sort of
like like my system's been set not at
ease but thinking about it in a really
seemingly time sensitive and pressured
way library of Babel was one of these um
and the Comedia was another it just
really led me to feel I hadn't really
related
to um religious belief before I read it
I was pretty you know I was I was raised
sort of like you know like like I'm I'm
I'm Hally Jewish but like you know
Jewish I I I was raised culturally
Jewish but but I didn't experience a lot
of firsthand involvement in practice of
faith and I was a pretty committed
atheist and then I was put face to face
with this system where I was being
spoken to directly through this text by
somebody whose life is driven by this
god-shaped hole and I started to feel it
and it changed my life I mean like I I I
was an atheist and I'm not which is one
of the biggest changes that that that a
book could possibly Implement in you
right um yeah and I just find I find the
Comedia to be this sort
of really Timeless really meaningful
really gripping
story um it's archetypal in a lot of
ways but it also has a bunch of really
weird idiosyncrasies that stick with you
um and that can't sort of be resolved by
any Claim about oh it's drawing from
this it's a hero's journey and it's this
happens it doesn't follow formula in
those kinds of way can't be schematized
away the ways which it doesn't follow
formula or things are just in there for
no reason really gets you to stick on it
like there's an example that I always
use which is at the very end of Paradiso
um and Dante is so beatric has gone back
to her position in like the beautiful
flower of the of the Divine like every
you know all the saints are pedals and
and beatric is is in hers and Dante is
looking up at her and she doesn't seem
to be aware that he that that he's
looking at her and what she's doing is
sort of just screwing around she she's
making a crown for herself by doing
superhero crap with light she's bending
light rays to make a crown for herself
and Dante is looking in on her on this
this extremely intimate and just very
bizarre moment that clearly was not
meant to be perceived like that kind of
thing in the Comedia is just
so that keeps you there I mean yeah
story about finding God and beholding
the beauty of God but there's also stuff
like that where it really it takes that
old you know um adage of God works in
mysterious ways and it's like let me
show you some of those mysterious ways
these things are weird I just find that
extremely beautiful extremely confusing
in a motivating way I it's why I picked
the name Virgil for myself I mean it
shows you that there's a richness to the
human interaction with the Divine that
often gets left out in our theology
izing about it and I'm going to throw an
idea at you that I've I've said in many
other places and see what you make of
this um I I'm somebody who like grew up
Catholic but it's kind of similar to
what you were describing nobody actually
knew anything you know we went to to
what's called CCD which is uh catechesis
and Christian doctrine and it was a
total waste of time it was the 1970s and
1980s and then I went to a Catholic High
School and I left the church while I was
in the high school and they were so you
know tolerant that they were like H you
know you have to go to mass but you
don't have to stand up you can protest
with your buddies if you want to you
know and uh it was only later on um I
mean I'd go to church at Christmas time
and Easter with my family is just a kind
of proor thing right and then I um I was
reading anel and aquinus just to work on
my Latin and I was like holy these
guys really are amazing you know and the
people that on is something yeah the
when you first read it the people who
were like oh this is just you know these
are just Faith people they don't really
know anything you know my professors I
was like well I guess they don't know
what the hell they're talking about I
better read more of this stuff right and
what I always found so here's the thing
I want to like shoot at you and see what
you think about it I've always found the
religious thinkers that are worth my
spending time with are the ones for whom
religion or faith or God whatever you
want to talk about it as didn't make
things simple and didn't resolve their
problems it made the world more
complicated but more rich and you know
this like what you were talking about
introducing these these these moments
were like well beus is you know she's a
creature of God so in a certain way her
messing around doing this seemingly
random thing it's not that God directly
is doing something but God is allowing
that to be the the case so what the
hell's going on it very much is a manif
a of the glory of God while she's doing
this in the book and it's framed that
way um you're totally you're totally
right and I and I relate a lot to that
sentiment that the kinds of religious
thinkers that really challenged my and
I'm I I'll come out and admit it I was
very much like a sort of like annoying
Reddit
atheist um well I think I was probably
because Reddit didn't exist at that time
equivalent of that back then no I like
read you know oh my gosh I've read
Dawkins is God
I agreed with every word and then you
know I I still like at at my parents
house there's a copy of it and every so
often I'll like leave through trying to
capture what it was like to be that
person because it's such a profound
disconnect between the way my mind
worked then in the way it works now and
I'll just be like what did I ever see in
this yeah but I
really I was I was very selective when I
say selectively it comes off as if I
mean intentionally like there are some
sneaky people who are doing this but I
don't mean it that way I just mean this
is sort of the way that Society
inevitably got organized yeah I was only
confronted selectively
with the the the testimony of people who
seem to be deploying their faith towards
as an explanatory device right towards
explaining things yeah whereas the kinds
of the the the variety of faith that
could in principle be gripping to me and
ended up being gripping to me and
changing me is where Faith itself needs
to be explained
which ironically is also the motivating
condition for new
atheism um it's the motivational quest
of why do people think this why do we
feel this way they just end up they just
sort of I don't know there's certain
stance right they take a very reductive
stance I think that's the issue they
seem to be there's this sort of
reduction out
of I'm I'm I'm sensitive to use the word
the phrase emotional reality ities
because I've been following this Hassan
minhaj story
um but um there's there's this reduction
out of people's emotional states in
relation to their apprehension of Truth
yeah which is of course actually
inimitable I mean just it just isn't
true that facts don't care about your
feelings or if it is true then too bad
my feeling doesn't care about that fact
exactly um people are motivated in
specific Ways by certain gripping ideas
ideas by certain commit commitments even
commitments to abstract logical
principles are felt emotionally and the
relationship you know to to the Divine
or to one or more Divine beings is
necessarily going to
be um self-aware it's necessarily going
to be emotional it's necessarily going
to be sort of like this mirror thing of
regarding oneself in conversation with
something and it's really difficult to
apprehend if you don't feel it it's a
it's a really tricky communication
barrier you know it's interesting
because you can have the it's sort of
like having a relationship with a A you
know regular human
being you can have um moments or even
long periods where you knew that you did
feel something now you're not feeling it
like what you know they call the Dark
Knight of the Soul or things like that
right and and it it's difficult to to
deal with because um there is that
temptation to say well I'm not feeling
it so I'm just going to go back to doing
whatever I was doing but you know that
whatever you were doing wasn't really
good for you right and you know
apparently some people like Mother
Teresa struggled with this for like 50
years of her life she heard God once
whatever hear God means to her and then
she like committed herself and then she
never had anything after that you know
uh and people do say oh you know she was
she was kind of doing bad things here
and there and you know if if I had 50
years of like like you called it the the
how did you put it the god shaped
god-sized God shed hole Yeah I mean if I
had a like the feeling in your soul that
there is something that you incline
towards that is it I wouldn't have been
taking care of lepers you know even if I
was like maybe grandstanding a bit I
would I would you know I wouldn't be
like a a mass murder or something but I
sure as hell would be in despair if I
felt that for 50 years you know um it's
very or I mentioned Teresa vava earlier
oh right right right and she goes on and
on so for her it was very much of ping
ponging where she would be experiencing
these like extremely visceral Salient
Visions with like all sorts of sensory
elements you know she was a she was a
Mystic she was one of the massive
affective elements too and then and then
she was sort of it's it's sort of funny
to read her um Auto
reading this book with sort of the
hermen that we have now of the way in
which relationships between people
progress and are perceived yeah
experiencing these these these feelings
and these and these sentiments and these
visions and sounds and all of this and
then she went to her confessors and they
understandably because imagine if
somebody came to you and said this were
like this is the work of the
devil and you need to you need to put
your different hermeneutics of like cing
back then but you need to put stick up
your middle finger at it the next time
that it comes at you
and then the next time that she has a
vision she feels really bad about it but
she does stick up her middle finger
because that's what her confessors told
her to do and then the vision
says
listen I I am real but I understand that
the tricky State you've been placed in
and I bless you for adhering to your
confessor's advice to stick your middle
finger at me which sounds like the kind
of thing God would say right like like
so there's this there's this back and
forth where it's there's an internal
doubt she's experiencing there's an
internal doubt because other people
aren't you know think her Visions are
Preposterous and then there's this sort
of ineliminable very obvious reality
that she confronts whenever she has a
vision it's really so so it really
distills in clear terms the strangeness
the the space and and the Ping ponging
often back and forth between doubt and
like visceral certainty yeah I mean even
anel the prian he says that you know
when he's recalling
the whatever it was that he he
discovered and we're not really sure if
it's the formula Kon poest or it's like
the whole of the UNAM argumentum which
is all of the prian minus the last three
chapters um you know he says that I
started trying to think about this thing
it started obsessing me I you know it's
distracting me from prayers I thought
this is obviously got to be from the
devil so he's being his own like um
Confessor in this respect part because
there's nobody else in his Abby who
could do it I mean herin the Abbot is
just some old Warrior you know he's not
a sophisticated guy Lon Fran is left
anel is the prior so he's gotta kind of
straighten himself yeah he's his own
critic yeah so you know he he tries to
push it away and then he you know it
starts obsessing him and he's like yeah
definitely of the devil um and then
there's that breakthrough that happens
and um during prayers and he says okay I
I got it now and he goes and writes it
down on his wax tablets which um
according to his biographer get broken
and then he has to write it down again
and commits it to to paper um this
reminds me of um you know Maria the AGA
I don't she was this is like this is a
weird apocryphal story this so there
there was this she she was a nun it sort
of like you know I think this was sort
of the height of the the the Catholic
Reformation
um when you know there are sort of like
Catholic Mystics around who are
revitalizing Catholic culture after the
Protestant split and she was so she
claimed that um the Virgin Mary was
coming to her and dictating her as in
Mary's Auto agog graphy oh and Maria AA
was writing all of this down and she
ended up with this 3,000 page
autobiography that she alleged was
dictated to her by by St Mary she goes
to her confessors and to like the Mother
Superior and they're like throw this
away this is terrible yeah and and she
does and then at some point later that
there's a different there there are
different people in charge and the new
Mother Superior says hey you know Marita
AA why don't I'm interested to see what
you'd written um about about the life of
St Mary and Maria says oh I had to burn
it my confessors told me too and the the
the
um the the Mother Superior says can you
can you rewrite it and she does and she
rewrites all of it from scratch and then
she brings it yeah and now it's it's
this it's this absurdly long book it's
called the mystical city of God okay um
you I mean you can find it around you
can find full text of it and there's
English translations of it and I've read
it and it's really strange I've wrote A
lot of my a lot of my undergraduate work
was on it because there's a lot of
really interesting weird features about
it one of the Paradigm features of these
Catholic Mystics was that they and this
is very bores
esque they were very verbose and
long-winded okay but often the upshot of
their really long paragraphs would be
that talking is bad so like for instance
in mystical city of God it's it's so
long like it's just cartoonishly long
and but then and then there are whole
chapters so she's talking about Mary's
early life and she's saying well Mary is
born with per without say him with full
cognitive capacity
um so she could talk as a baby but she
chose not to she only spoke in prayer
and then as she's extoling Mary's virtue
that she didn't speak as a baby even
though she could this biographer Maria
de AA is writing paragraphs and
paragraphs and paragraphs about it and
it's like is communicating bad or not
like it's it's very funnily
contradictory in that way and I wrote a
lot about that and that's also something
that that's also something that comes
across and Boris where it's like he is
writing and writing and writing and yet
it seems if you take it at face value
the upshot of this short story is
despair because the written word is
useless that very much seems if you take
it at face value the upshot of the
immortal and the upshot of library and I
don't think that it actually is a
correct interpretation but that same
sort of implicit tension is there you
could say that there's a similar
thematic in the god script and in the
circular ruins except I mean they both
involve
uh writing in a certain way but they
also involve a like realizing that that
wherever you are you're not the real
thing you know so there's a a
possibility of Despair in in those as
well I'd say you know yeah and in ver
was the
search there yeah well we should talk
about uh the lottery in Babylon so you
you want to give like a summary for
because I'm sure most of our uh viewers
and and listeners haven't uh read that
story and they should
right okay this one's trickier because
it's not really a narrative yeah story
it just
describes a bunch of stuff and I'm not
sure I'll get the order right
um well if you do that's chance so
there so the the lottery in Babylon is
is is narrated by some man who you can
infer as a citizen of the empire of
Babylon it's not clear whether this is
meant to be the actual historical
Babylon or not um at some point in the
history of this
Empire um the practice of Lottery right
you know like like casting lots and then
they're winners and some people get
rewards became instantiated through Vari
variety of mechanisms into basically the
whole government so um everybody
participates in this Lottery um it has
these sort of weird Mystic or religious
elements where you're writing things on
sacred tablets and you have to consult
with the stone lion statues but I'm not
going to include that in the summary um
everybody you know draws these lots and
they dictate your fate up to an
extraordinarily minute and specific
degree so it can be that you know one
one Lottery outcome says that you are
going to get married the next Lottery
outcome says to whom the next one says
when and then the fourth one calls the
whole thing off and then the fifth one
UNC calls it off like it's almost an
infinitely recursive thing where
additional information is always
provided that can extend or change or
negate the previous verdicts of this
lottery so basically Society becomes
entirely governed by this this this
Lottery that all of the members of
society are playing um there's a variety
of speculations about the people who are
arranged in some organization or
institution who run the lottery who are
known known as the the company in the
Hurley
translation um and some others it's the
corporation or the Enterprise oh
interesting um in my not done
translation of this I
um I call it I call it the Enterprise
okay um but basically they they there
are various worries about the
motivations these people and whether
things are truly up to chance they issue
a memo um in that sort of says well if
there are errors that just makes it even
more chance and everyone's thoroughly
convinced by this um things s things
continue on as they are um there's not
really any plot and the story just
resolves sort of sort of Suddenly It's
hinted throughout that the narrator is
like waiting for for a boat or something
yeah um and and there's sort of various
other indicators that maybe Society has
totally Fallen to ruin because of the
lottery
but it's not really it's not really said
explicitly and it could just be the case
that he's waiting for a boat for no
reason all right I
mean it it's centered in
Babylon and you get this Narrative of
the development you know stage by stage
by stage and and we do have a like what
seems to be an unreliable narrator we
can't be sure whether he says nobody can
really be sure about these these
historical things um but but I'm going
to tell you the story anyway and it's
it's a plausible tale about
how something that would start out as
just one part of society would um
determine the entirety of society now
why couldn't this go the ton route and
infect the entire world if if
bab that's that's your interpretation of
it that it that he he is saying that
like the whole world is is uh B
oh oh no I mean that is very much the
fact that this is the upshot of I think
it's interesting that even in his
similar stories yeah no they're not the
same and I mean that in more than just a
cursory way I mean the particular
upshots of society's adoption of some
way of interaction or other tend to be
different so like in on exactitude in
science um everybody
leaves um and if you don't read it
carefully it's only a par but if you
don't read on exactitude in science
carefully you misinterpret it terribly
what actually happens is that
everybody is leaves the whole empire and
it just goes to ruins and nobody lives
there anymore um then in in in library
of Babel they sort of just do
nothing um in Salon yeah yeah it it
comes and infects Earth even though it
was made up in the first place and
everything becomes a disaster and we're
all going to die every the resolutions
like what what's going to happen next is
is is often different in stories that
have this same sort of focus of well
here's a particular kind of linguistic
Endeavor or here's a theory of language
or here's just a new language yeah and
here's how it either poisons the
hermeneutic well or provide something
new and insightful or sort of backfires
horribly or you know whatever but
lottery in
Babylon I don't think it really
needs some
pervasive warning about oh the lottery
has spread to other continents and
everything is governed by Lottery now um
it it I think it sort of stands on its
own and I as with a lot of the stories
of vores that I really like I have a
pretty you know uh set in stone
interpretation okay of it but I want to
hear I want to hear
yours well I don't I don't uh it is my
favorite story but I don't have um
something that really works works as an
overall interpretation of it I I guess
I'm still kind of digging away at it I
I'm fascinated with how each stage leads
to the next you know and the there's
some sort of transition point you know
at the beginning you can't say that
anything is governed by chance in this
weird wacky way where chance is not just
drawing Lots but you've actually got the
structure of that that you know
organization that's administering it if
it does indeed exist right you just have
a lottery and then they start
introducing little things along the way
and these these eventually snowball into
this massive thing and and it you know
another thing I'm fascinated with with
this story is bores is attuned to um the
fact that this Lottery is satisfying
human needs and demands right so we we
have the the lottery isn't that
interesting when you can just win money
it gets more interesting when you can
lose money too yeah I have I have a
specific opinions about that I I think
that's very important and then and then
it turns into another key transition
point is it turns into non-monetary
penalties or rewards and then by the
time that you get done a lot of the
stuff isn't penalties or rewards
that at all you know um instead it's
it's more like
[Music]
um uh what would you call it um just
heterogenous things to use one of
Borge's favorite words just development
of Life development of events and he he
includes that one paragraph where he
talks about how there are small sort of
totally irrelevant non-personal outcomes
that are dictated by Lottery like the
release of some bird from a tower
yeah and so in the end you wind up with
something that in a way does satisfy y
human beings but they've completely
adapted to it now as well right so um
yeah you said you had an idea about that
first transition
Point um going from just just monetary
rewards and introducing other
inducements yes and it sort of is is
drawn from there becomes this back and
forth where it's like well does my
theory of what the story means draw from
these evidence or do I retrofit the
evidence to the theory whatever um okay
probably it's a it's a it's it's
dichotomous both directions of the
causality exist so all right there's a
bunch of commonly identified themes in
Lottery and Babylon right like chance
and determinism right are chance and
determinism separable as metaphysical
theories um there's a lot of stuff about
sort of the role and this isn't
something that particularly interests me
um but the role of magic mysticism and
religion in governing Society because
we're constantly let in on the way that
these shadowy you know like like the
organizers of the lottery are basically
priests and they're sort of
ritualistically discerning and they're
appealing to these statues and then they
tell people not to go to the statues and
it's this strange relationship of power
and religion but what I think is most
Central that's made explicit throughout
the narrative is the lottery is a
metaphor metaphor and indeed an
instantiation of a state's power over
the lives of people who live in it and
the associated Psy drama that goes along
with that and this is okay I know this
is going to come across as you know a
leftist read and so Sumi because you
know what can I do but I really think
the directing force of the metaphor and
the reason why Lottery and Babylon hangs
together and what it means stems from
the interpretation of the lottery as
imposing carceral ISM it imposes the
police state and the Monopoly on Force
to which the company aspires and which
the company achieves through
progressively first there's negative
penalties as well then suddenly there's
jail right and then from jail it goes to
control and branding and then it goes
total control this Monopoly on force
that they quickly establish is necessary
to cause the deliberate Bings and
worsenings of people of people's
conditions that are outcomes of the
lottery yeah to witness the prerogative
that the lottery Runners have to do
those things and most importantly and
this I think is what the ultimate
meaning of the story is to establish and
make uh permeates Society in
underpinning logic by which the lottery
becomes a metaph a metaphysical
necessity of governance and an
undergoing theory of why things happen
like and this I think is where the
performing an ideological role in
eological function um the carceral state
becomes impossible to think around I
call this hermeneutic capture you just
can't imagine life without it like you
know you have decarceral lists who are
talking about right right we have to
like the conditions in prisons are
terrible this is a terrible institution
we need to dismantle prisons and the
natural uh way in which people tend to
engage with decarceral ideology I think
is to sort of be confused and find it
Preposterous they don't find it evil
they find it Preposterous right well how
could we possibly do that then there's
going to be dangerous people on the
street and Society will collapse the
carceral state is a societal necessity
um and I think that the the the way that
the lottery works here is in a similar
way it captures the minds of its
citizens everything precedes by Chance
the idea of things not proceeding by
chance is preposterous um so on the
history of the lottery right um yeah the
history of the narrated provides makes
it clear how this Lottery develops from
something that was basically irrelevant
to the functioning of society right it
was a random game some people were
playing yeah yeah into an instantiation
of this highly facilitated and
attuned justifying logic and actual sort
of like Monopoly on Force by by the
state and the thing that transforms the
lottery from being regarded as
uninteresting by people to being
regarded as interesting and facilitate
social buyin is the introduction of
penalty and punishment first pecuniary
and then punitive incarcerate um the
like like in the Hurley translation he
writes that the small risk um Peak The
public's interest right yeah um and so
we see that a procedure that starts out
logical and starts out driven by
primarily economic incentives transforms
through the interaction between that
institution Society into a carceral
structure so so at one paragraph
relatively early on I think when he's
talking about this it's the paragraph
you already brought up he
says he he basically says well the
company had to protect people who are
winning the lottery and had to make sure
that the losers were paying the fines
and so they got involved with the
government and made it such that people
who didn't pay the fines that they lost
would have to go to jail right but then
the people who were targeted in this way
chose to go to jail out of protest and
then the lottery changed such that that
instead of the amount of money you lost
it would just print the number of days
you had days right yeah and this was the
first um this is a quote it was the
first appearance of non-pecuniary
elements in the lottery um and and
people love this people are all here for
this yeah and then we see that once
introduced this logic of
carismo like it noded on its own tail um
and it extends to wield influence over
other elements of society as well so we
have we see this demand that's l
um in the next iteration of the lottery
after these first penalties have been
introduced where there's a demand for
equality where people rise up and it's
very perverse they're demanding to have
access to go to jail it's a perversion
of equality people are saying poor
people should also be allowed to play
the lottery yeah um and the logic really
I think is this beautiful this is why I
find this this metaphor so apt the logic
is the chance makes all people equal but
of course that's like are we really
going to agitate for everyone getting an
increased and therefore equal chance to
be imprisoned it's this sick perversion
of equality it's equality bent towards
these terrible
ends you know I think you're right
though because there I mean there are
the reward aspects right you could um oh
he's got the thing about you could you
know arrive in your room and there's a
woman waiting for you or there might be
a a serpent or something like that right
but there isn't any people are greedy
and want you know benefits to be doled
out to them
and that's why they're doing the
lottery um you know which is quite
different than say like the the
motivation like right now in our society
I was talking with my business ethics
students about this and some of them are
actually quite upset if you watch um you
know sports games like we watch NFL
football you're just deluged with ads
for sports betting things you know and
it's a celebrity a website called the
adct collective and i' that's right
right right yeah yeah go on go on I I'm
very interested to hear what you think
about this well you know the ads are not
like this this is a great possibility
for you to lose your college fund or you
know anything like that it's all hey man
you know there's we're going to give you
a hundred bucks to gamble with it's
going to be so fun for you look this
celebrity who you know is not playing
apps on their phone is is doing it this
is going to be amazing for you that's
usually the sell of these things or or
you know when we do lotteries you know
think about like our scratch offs and
stuff like that we're like oh it's going
to be good it's going to benefit
education we'll we'll make it serve some
social purpose um but you're right with
with the story the way that borase is
telling it it's the negative impact on
people that winds up being the draw and
so you can ask well what what you know
what's wrong with these people that they
want to be punished you know uh but that
that's a a a you know question that gets
raised by all all sorts of literary
figures think about uh Edgar Allen Po's
the impa the perverse or dostv is the
the underground man you know um there's
this tendency to like seek out our
own theu there's there's one metaphor
there's one uh not there's one analogy I
think is particularly apt which is to
those who walk away from omalos oh yeah
yeah kwin
which the the the framing of the story
is very I don't know if you you you've
read the full text yeah yeah okay so the
framing of the story is very clearly
laid out that she is providing the story
of this sort of injured tortured child
in the basement as like a ritualistic
concession to her readers to make the
story interesting and she says that very
blatantly yeah she says listen I've told
you about a really great society where
everyone's happy all the time but what's
fashionable right now for reasons that I
never understood is that stories can't
be interesting unless they're tragic and
sad and upsetting and miserable and so
for that reason fine you want to hear
about this Society be Mis being
miserable I'll invent a tortured
child yeah there has to be some harm
somewhere there has to be some sort of
trade-off there has to be a negative
experience
yeah so so you so you see borase is
doing something kind of similar but on a
much larger well I mean it's not a much
larger scale right becauseas is entire
Society um yeah it's that that's a very
compelling take you know and it does fit
the text
um it's interesting too
because so if the company exists or the
corporation company exists okay so
you're should I okay should I just like
lay out go ahead lay lay out the the
yeah the case for
that okay so we so we've seen now that
using this sort of weird like you know
people people are agitating for the
right to have their lives too dominated
by this Lottery it derives more explicit
power um it controls the government and
the power of the lottery draws
legitimacy from its apparent equality
the lottery is made open to all um it's
no longer lots aren't sold um you
automatically are given apart right as a
citizen Midway through the story the
company writes this Manifesto which is
sort of like the central Point um where
they're accused of H corruption right
which is our sensibly a claim against
equality right the interest of Lottery
has been equality and then the company
is being accused of favoritism or being
accused of like not really tossing dice
maybe to get these outcomes and they
write a Manifesto and they write it in
like the ash on the ground it's very
right yeah I don't know what that's
about I don't really think it whatever
they they write this Manifesto in which
they detail the relationship between
chance and leg legitimacy um they write
this letter in the land they say and I
quote according to Hurley the lottery is
an interpretation of chance and sorry
the lottery is an interpolation of
chance into the order of the universe
and to accept errors is to strengthen
chance not contravene it so they are
saying that actually this deployment of
you know quote unquote favoritism or
what have you is conducive to the chance
driven universe and then the public not
only accepts this logic but proceeds to
take it further they say well chance
should intervene in every aspect of the
drawing it shouldn't just be a draw Lots
once then we have to have and then we
descend into like bores just loves
Zeno's Paradox and this is an
opportunity for him to like go you know
like like like drum on Zeno's Paradox
for a while he loves this he does it in
death in the compass he does like he
does this all the time and he you know
no no decision is is going to be the
last one you have infinitely subdivided
time and then the narrator says this
sentence the ignorant assume that
infinite drawings require infinite time
actually all that is required is that
time be infinitely subdivis as in the
famous parable of the race with the
tortoise right yeah but that's of course
silly and Boris knows that that's the
comment he's making is that it's silly
obviously if you have empirical people
who are really occupying space and
interacting in the world you cannot use
the infinite subdivis ability of time to
do infinite things in finite time that's
just not how the world works and I think
that this comment by the narrator
is an indicator and there's often there
there are often things like this in
boris's other stories this is an
indicator that the narrator isn't
reliable okay the narrator has become a
mouthpiece for the because he's he's
introducing things that are a clue uh
telling us if we're attentive that this
can't possibly be the case right it it
sort of indicates this person's
metaphysics of reality are just so way
off they've been like shaped and and
changed to f it's the narrative that he
thinks about this Lottery and the way in
which reality works oh okay so he's he's
not being deceptive like no no no the
narrator believes this and that's sort
of where I think the cism metaphor has
the greatest punch the narrator has been
tricked into believing that the company
controls every facet of Destiny and he
sort of like mathed himself into
thinking that the company wields
infinite power in finite time which of
course is bizarre but but but it happens
on the inductive side not on the
positive side he's not observing is true
he's speculating it he's saying
hypothesize posit the story of the race
of the toris he's not saying oh yeah I
went there and they were just their
hands are moving faster and faster and
they did infinite things it's it's that
he's assuming that all of these
happenings are results of the lottery um
and as the explicit power of the lottery
goes Its explanatory Force as a theory
of why things happen gross too the
lottery becomes not necessarily
responsible but assumed to be
responsible for why everything happens
in society and and bores thus hints at
this unreliability the narrator the same
thing happens in library of Babel
actually which has a lot of
commonalities almost like similarly
structured sentences a lot okay um the
there's a there's a sentence um where
Bor where where the narrator says I
myself in this hurried statement have
misrepresented some Splendor some
atrocity for right right yeah and he's
talking about how under the influence of
the company the documents because
they're driven by chance tend to have
errors in them this is again a similar
theme from library of Babel and then
he's admitting that he's probably that's
another sort of hint so we have this
sort of you know like blatant
contradiction um and that's where we
leave out at sort of the the we right
when we're about to get into this thing
that like where does the company exist
or not what we've been driven toward is
this blatant contradiction which is the
focus of the story um and it's clearly
distilled in the narrator's worry about
represent misrepresentation given his
conflation between chance and error and
the contradiction is this why is the
narrator worried shouldn't he be calm in
the knowledge that if he were meant to
write things differently the lottery
would have willed it like he seems to
sincerely believe that all of his
Destiny is driven by this apocryphal and
secret and you know Lottery and yet he
seems to be afraid that he's misstated
something and that is this strange
conflict so this gets to
like there's there's something very
mathematical here okay um I don't know I
don't know how far should go into math
but there is something that's big in the
philosophy of Statistics um which is
which is and the history of philosophy
of Statistics more more specifically
which is this concept called boral's
Paradox okay or Le Paradox de Boral as
steinhouse called it in 1909 um Emil
borell proves this theorem um about C
about decimal
expansions um which is called the strong
law of absolutely normal numbers
basically that the theorem that he
proves establishes that these two things
that are viewed as
contradictory one if you look out in the
long run out into the infinitude of
decimal expansions of real numbers the
vast majority of numbers they're like
ratios the the relative frequency and
population of ones and of twos and
threes and so on and up to nines and
zeros yeah is all is each going to be
on10th it's sort of equidistributed the
chance is equal yeah yeah and then
here's the other so so there's like a
global regularity there that there's a
uniform chance and then here's the other
thing which seems to be contradictory
against that is that if you look into
the immediates if you if you take some
individual decimal point that you're at
you have no way of knowing what comes
next it could be anything and in
particular you're probably not going to
see like 1 2 3 4 5 six seven 8 9 Z in a
row in fact you're probably not going to
see within some 100 digits that there's
10 zeros 10 ones 10 twos and so on so
there's a local sort of Randomness or
irregularity contrasting with a global
sense of regularity and law- likeness
there's a universal logic and it's
contrasted with noise in the here and
now it's a conflict between large large
scale patterns and small scale ones and
this is a big thing in science and it
was big at the time that bores was
writing um when there was a big you know
the the contrast between like
cosmological versus particle physics was
really big the you know the the the the
um
the the large the bodies of large mass
are governed by this sort of like
nutonian sense right like they obey this
this gravitational relation but then
when we look at the tiny things they
seem to operate in this totally distinct
way and this is very confusing or even
just like the Earth is a globe we know
but if you look if you're standing in
some place and look it looks flat
yeah so that I think like I know it's
very like it's it's funny and Bor has
really draws I think from a lot of these
very mathematical or scientific
vodes so he has his his narrator as as a
casualty of this weird idiosyncratic
contradiction where there's what there's
noise on the small scale but then
there's Grand universality and sensical
on the large scale and this is sort of
self-contradictory in a
way but the noise is being interpreted
by every person in Babylon as if it is
meaningful and
legitimate right and that would be
different than in the rest of the world
where they look in from the outside and
they're like can you believe these
people you know they just accept all
this crazy crap going on you
know right I mean it's like from inside
the system it seems to make sense they
have this pic letter that was written by
the company and that now is among the
Sacred Scriptures that says actually
these kinds of perturbations actually
increase Randomness yeah yeah and this
self-contradiction extends I mean
I think really like one of the the very
first paragraph of the story comes
across in this way that allows borus to
sneak in one of these major reveals
ahead of time he starts it off what does
it say I have been I have been I been
Pro Consul I have been right yeah yeah
and so on and he keeps talking and it's
like a it is the best of times it's the
worst of right like he's doing this
contrast thing but then later on he's
the narrator says once for an entire
year I was declared invisible I would
cry out and one would heed my call I
would steal bread and not be beheaded
and this taking this sentence I think is
really interesting because it
demonstrates that even in this world
that internally is deemed to be governed
totally and completely by the lottery we
see that cause and effect can't entirely
be governed by chance even in the mental
relations of the people who are
subsuming their lives to the lottery the
narrator right is recognizing the fact
that his stealing bread but avoiding the
logical consequence of being beheaded
is contradictory he he's recognizing the
fact that the lottery has suspended some
natural law that would exist in its
absence yeah yeah if that weren't the
case then it would just be like well he
can steal breed or not and then whether
he's going to be beheaded depends on
some separate draw I mean preexistence c
logic that term interpolation I mean
should we interpret it as the the the
lottery the organization inserts bits of
chance like here and there it's not
chance Alto together it's just like
almost like grafts in a way like onto a
tree or something like that it graft
onto a pre-existing structure okay and
sort of make sense out of it in much the
way that the combinatorial theory of you
know why these letters are where they
are grafts onto the
pre-existing um like observations about
the library and from there we get a
theory one of the most famous things in
the in the in the story which I wonder
is if you like it's one of these neat
things it's that thing where somebody
steals a lottery ticket oh yeah and a
lottery ticket say you do you want to
relay this part to the audience so if I
remember it rightly it's it's
um they were supposed to be put to death
uh because of it right and I forget the
mode of it or were they supposed to just
be
branded um either way I think it's
branded but they're a slave and so
stealing as a slave punishment right and
the punishment is is we'll say it's
branded being branded for that but the
ticket also says this person's supposed
to be branded and so you know you'd say
well it doesn't matter because you're
going to get branded no matter what but
the people get obsessed with it and
they're like does he get branded because
he stole the ticket or does he get
branded because the ticket he stole says
get branded and then that leads to you
know I mean it's a it's a weird Paradox
that I guess you could say is
manufactured it doesn't have to exist as
a paradox but for that Society it
becomes um one of those turning points
where now we can we got to figure things
out differently you know yeah exactly
it's it's really interesting there he
seals this ticket the ticket says you
get uh oh it's getting his tongue burned
out I guess oh that's right yeah isn't
what I would have guessed but the so so
getting your tongue burned out is
ostensibly the penalty for theft yeah
but it's also the the ticket also says
the holder of this ticket gets their
tongue burned out and people argue about
whether the person deserves get to get
their tongue burned out because the
ticket says so or because that's the law
and this I think is a beautiful
distillation like this is just sort of
the kind of reason why I think this is a
story about carceral ISM because this
sort of absurdist logic that it matters
because of because as you point out of
course it doesn't matter they're arguing
about why to do something they've
already they all agree that they're
going to do yeah um and and it's sort of
this strange that I think really
distills how the advance of the lottery
is not about changing Society it's it's
entirely explanatory who even knows
whether outcomes change as a result of
what the lottery tickets say or whether
what's happening is that people are
coming to think that what happens to
them is now Justified because is what
their lottery ticket says so like it
obviously can't be true that the lottery
dictates all happenings this is about
perception not reality and yet the the
the author is sort of helplessly
interpreting events as caused by the
lottery like he does in that one section
where he talks about the in itely
subdivis lottery or he talks about like
somebody being murdered or like like
outcomes 30 or 40 drawings build on each
other and things get more and more
specific and then sometimes this kind of
ridiculousness gets more open there's a
paragraph We mentioned this earlier that
that that bores talks about impersonal
drawings or the drawings about natural
events yeah where there's a drawing that
like decrees that like a bird's going to
be released from the top of a tower or
not yeah and there's a drawing that says
that one grain of sand every hundred
years has to to be added to or
subtracted from a beach yeah and and
then and there's a sentence at the end
of that paragraph where the author has
enumerated there are lotteries about
whether the bird is released there are
lotteries about whether the sand is
changed he says sometimes the
consequences are terrible and I think
it's easy to misread this as a butterfly
butterfly flaps its wing story like yeah
oh the catastrophic compounding effects
of chance ra you know here we are we
stand you know immutably tragic no it's
not that at all I think what we're
really seeing is that the narrator is
hysterical a grain of sand is added to a
beach big whoop birds are released from
a tower like what's going to happen a
bird strike there are no planes this is
Babylon yeah yeah there's no like
nothing nothing is possibly going to
happen I think what we're seeing here is
that the narrator when later you know
like his City gets attacked or somebody
you know like like some somebody has a
difficult child birth or somebody falls
and gets injured or an election doesn't
turn out the way he wanted he is
retroactively interp preting it as
caused by these weird oneoff additions
of sand to the beach because he has
ascribed this tremendous explanatory
power the lottery into the underg chance
you know um when you put it like that so
you know very often when bad things
happen to people if people are
religiously inclined and sometimes even
when they're not they'll be like well
God's you know plan God moves in
mysterious ways Divine Providence and
all that sort of stuff so if you a
lottery like this you can be like we
don't need God in the picture you know
it's just a chance sucks for you buddy
but uh you know that's that's the uh the
shakes that you get um so you can have
the the effect of passivity in the face
of of Badness that that people
experience without the hard to prove
hard to justify oh there's there's a
reason for all of this I mean the reason
is well there was some stupid random
drawing that doesn't mean anything and
you know it just happened to to play out
like that there is one thing I maybe
that isn't the reason but but the fact
that it the fact that it could be or
that it in principle is believed to be
yeah changes how people interact with
the world that's right yeah yeah I
before we wrap up because I I'm gonna
have to get going myself soon um I did
want to bring up one thing about like
the carceral thing and go back to like
we were talking about the contrast
between how it looks from the outside
and the inside and and I used to teach
in in prisons and one of the things that
I I thought a lot about because my
relatives would complain about you know
how these these guys are getting a free
education and they're being treated too
nicely and all that sort of stuff um the
biggest complaint that I see still today
is that prisoners have
TVs and you know from the outside this
this actually looks like an egregious
you know Injustice that we allow these
you know layabout criminals to have
access to television and it actually
even made its way into a Robert Audi um
piece that I uh teach in my my classes
where he's like this is clear you know
Injustice send it to me sounds like
something that would make me angry yeah
so when you're inside though you see
what the function of letting them have
TVs is first of all they got to pay a
ton of money because it's bought on the
commissary so they you know they make
very little money they spend it on on a
TV and now it's something you know the
the guards love for prisoners to have TV
and it's not just because it keeps them
busy in their cells and not doing doing
other stuff it's because it's one more
thing you can take away from them if
they screw up so it like enforces
compliance and um you know if if you
were to say okay we're going to be tough
on these these prisoners no more TVs the
people who would Revolt would be the
guards because they'd be like you're
making our jobs way more dangerous man
you know and uh and there's a there's a
bread and circus element to it yep for
sure yeah yeah well um what we should do
before we we go because this has been a
fascinating conversation and I you know
I wish it could go on longer um where
can people best find you we've talked
about a number of different things um
you're on Twitter um are you on other
social media where people can no no I'm
I never really figured out how to use
Instagram I don't know what to put
pictures
um I'm I'm on Twitter at Virgil or30
okay which you know for interested uh
list I Virgil is is is is my name and uh
30 is the number of the kto of
purgatorio where Virgil is observed by
Dante P to be gone okay so Virgil or30
uh I guess that'll only that's only a
good nemonic if you're a a Dante fan but
that is why I chose it sure um the the
blog that I run is addict collective.
substack do.com uh we also have a
Discord which people can feel free to
join which is linked in the in the blog
um but yeah and I'm I'm around you know
just like shout a bad take about bores
out your window and I might show up
that's I think how we we first started
interacting uh isn't it
or yeah somebody tweeted something about
boras and I am I'm always up on you know
quote tweeting that
hating it yeah well I just like I don't
know it's a good it's a good venue
there's a lot of Boris fans on and about
academic Twitter yeah I think that that
that's quite true um so thanks so much
for for coming on um this is this is
great and I look forward to Future
conversations about boraste and other
things we ranged over a ton of different
topics uh some boraste related some not
is there anything you want to go out on
as like last words or uh got a pithy
quote or whatever whatever it is that
you
want okay I guess I will I'll end with a
comment a conclusion of the like
carceral metaphor I was trying to
describe about Lottery uh which is that
at the very something we were talking
about repeatedly throughout this
conversation is there's
this suspicion throughout the story that
the company itself that runs this
Lottery may not actually exist right um
and by later sort of heresy arcs in this
in this imagined world it's hypothesized
not to actually exist um and there's
this upshot that even though this
company has total power the fact that
his power is interpreted stemming from
the natural order namely chance seems to
make its existence Superfluous that's
the underlying logic of the letter that
the company people scrawled in the in
the St the sand in the smoke the idea is
this is just the way things happen yeah
um and if there's one thing that I think
you know the stories can motivate us to
action to politic to emotional
catharsist to to what have
you I think bores is rejecting this and
I think we should too that this is not
just the way things happen this is not
just the way that people behave and in
the case of you know the carceral
metaphor we can and should question the
idea that carceral Society was written
in the stars ahead of time in in in
Russo state of nature this is just the
way people behave People Are retributive
People
vindictive um and in so far as there is
an institution that imposes that order
it's Superfluous in the first place
because people will always come together
and create carceral ISM which I think is
a lot of the justificatory force of
those state of nature Parables um I
think that Bor has is critiquing that
and I think it's good to critique um I
don't think you know you don't have to
be a decarceral um obviously I am but
but but the fact of the matter is that
when it comes to these kinds of peculiar
roles played by logic and our reasoning
not restricted to politics even but also
in our mathematics and our philosophy
and our interpretation of other texts um
this is just the way things are this is
just the way people behave can and
should be questioned especially when it
allows us to let an ostensibly active
agent get away with something which is
what's happening with the company in in
the lottery story all right well again
thanks so much for for coming on I'm
sure that there'll be a lot of uh
comments from from people and I I'll
I'll try to send them your way as
well thanks so much for having me this
is such a great project and I hey I will
be on speed dial for that 14in Infinity
Project yeah that would be a really a
cool book to to
produce